ça répond à une forte demande il ya plus
de la moitié de la population jeune et
en demande de travail les seniors
également des difficultés à trouver des
activités par eux mêmes en tant que
salarié est là la solution alternative
c'est de créer sa propre activité en
étant évidemment accompagne et guide et
non seulement par ce type de sites
financés par erasmus mais également en
trouvant des partenaires locaux qui
peuvent relayer ces initiatives
l'idée c'est de développer un réseau qui
permet à des porteurs de projets non
seulement de travailler sur leurs
plateformes et aussi de connecter
d'autres plateformes d'autres sites
d'autres régions d'afrique de l'europe
et de mettre en commun leurs compétences
et la recherche de marchés huit
entreprises et organismes d'europe donc
des islandais chypriote belges italiens
espagnol des canaries les antilles
évidemment qui sont venus nous rejoindre
en fait pour partager ce projet il se
mettre également en commun c'est à dire
avoir un référentiel d'outils de moyens
à travers un site dont l'accès est
gratuit s'appelle solos étirés preneur
point de vue est également d'avoir des
outils à leur disposition des tutoriels
pour faciliter leur réussite et leur
introduction sur le marché du travail en
tant qu'auto-entrepreneur ans non
seulement sert de relève on est pilote
du projet donc c'est particulièrement
intéressant de montrer qu'une
association de martinique peut piloter
un projet européen dimensionné avec des
acteurs disséminés un peu partout dans
les régions ultra périphériques de
l'europe et réussir en fait dans le dans
la réalisation de ce projet